one year ago wuhan was in the first
tight grip of the pandemic the who said
they came here with four theories about
the origins of covet 19.
they'll leave tomorrow with just three
first
a direct zoonotic spillover that is
a direct transmission from an animal our
initial findings suggest
that the introduction to an intermediary
host species
is the most likely pathways connected to
this
hypothesis is also the one including
the possibility of transmission through
the trade of frozen cold chain
products however the findings suggest
that the
laboratory incident
hypothesis is
extremely unlikely of the four
hypotheses the only one you
decisively rejected was the laboratory
incident can you explain
uh the evidence or the reasoning for
discarding that hypothesis
nowhere previously was this particular
virus
researched or identified or known
there'd be no
publication no reports
of this virus of another virus extremely
linked or closely linked to this being
worked
with in any other laboratory in the
world for two weeks the experts have
been shuttled around wuhan in buses
as they conducted their investigation
they insisted it had been useful
they visited the seafood market where
the first big
coveted cluster was centered but this is
no longer
a smoking gun
many early reported cases were
associated with juanan market
indicating that it was one of the
focuses of transmission
nevertheless transmission was also
occurring elsewhere in wuhan at the same
time
and they came here to the wuhan
institute of virology
the trump administration had suggested
kovid was the result of a leak from
these labs
an idea dismissed by many as a
conspiracy theory
much of the world's attention has
focused on this lab and researchers
inside did handle coronaviruses
although they've always rejected the
possibility of a leak
the wha has spoken to them it agrees
with them and says the world should be
looking elsewhere
no photos oh no photos we were told to
look elsewhere too and
no no visit and china has been clear the
who investigation here
is done any further research must take
place
outside its borders tom cheshire sky
news wuhan